and if it doesn't work well then you
have to decompose the
you have an explanation for in some
sense a representation of everything
it's just low resolution
like like think of the word sky
okay that's an e that's that's that's an
icon the word is an icon so you could
think the word is a representation of an
image of a representation of reality
so when you look at the sky you don't
see the sky like let's say you're
looking up in the night sky i mean god
live there's a hundred billion galaxies
up there you don't see them
you see a low-res representation and
then you make that even lower res by
saying sky
well is that good enough well it's good
enough you don't get hit by a meteor
when you're out there on the deck
standing looking up at the sky because
it it does the trick for the time
that's a pragmatic preg that's a
pragmatic approach to truth to some
degree
you know it works well enough for your
current purposes
complete enough for you to act in the
manner that produces the result you
you want not the result you predict the
one you actually want it doesn't always
hurt like that yeah it's not
normal of course not because because
it's partly because our our low res reps
our representations are fallible
immensely fallible
but often they're good enough
you know when you were speaking to
harris what i thought was underlying the
disagreement between you two and even
with you and brett weinstein about truth
is that there's the implicit assumption
that one should pursue true so i don't
know if that's the case but when you're
referring to truth and you're saying
well here's the definition of truth and
if we were to just follow blindly
scientific truth we would build animals
which we have we could destroy us there
are many paths that can go that aren't
salutary so we should pick
and right we're saying well one is
explanatory well who cares about
explanatory we care about our life
to me what was at the un
to me what was underneath it was that we
should pursue truth is that am i correct
in my assessment or was there something
else
so what if one made the claim that we
don't always have to pursue truth
well we can't pursue it everywhere right
there has to be a spirit that animates
the pursuit of truth
to give it some direction well look
here's an example i think i probably
used this in my discussions with harris
i read this book once about um
biological warfare research in the
soviet union and it's pretty damn
relevant in the case of wuhan let's say
you know and god only knows what
happened there but
in any case demonetized right now there
were soviet scientists working on
combining
trying to make a hybrid
between smallpox and
ebola what's that that does the ebola
right right right right
and then to make it deliverable in
aerosols
well how about maybe not
how about maybe we don't go there
you know and and scientists are making
decisions like that all the time because
there's an infinite number of facts to
study see this is the problem with the
pure science argument follow the science
it's like well there's an infinite
number of facts this is a problem so
science is all about the facts yeah
which facts and then that gets us into
the post-modernist dilemma because the
post-modernists say only those facts
that serve the will to power and your
particular will to power that's this
very cynical way of looking at science
so
but but but there's still the question
there right something is directing this
some and something needs to be directing
this and and i would think harrison
weinstein and myself would all agree
that the pursuit of truth is of
exceptional importance and also that
there are methods for
distinguishing let's say
material facts scientific facts from
ethical facts now that's where it gets
trickier and the relationship between
those two
i don't think you can look at the facts
except through an ethical framework i
don't think it's possible
the ethical framework is built into your
perception
i see you can't help it and the reason
for that it's it's technically quite
straightforward i believe is that
we are fundamentally ambulatory and
goal-directed creatures
we walk we move we're always moving from
point a to point b always no matter what
even when we're looking at something
it's in preparation for a movement to
someone bet somewhere better
you know unless we're trying actively to
make things worse but that's an
exceptional case
we can't help but look at the world
what we see is a map that's a that's a
good way of thinking about it we don't
see the world we see our map of the
world and we need a map because we have
to walk through the world
and we don't want to have things fall on
us etc and we don't want to get lost
and so and then we we might infer
objects from the contents of our maps
and we might even say those objects are
fundamentally real but then you know
that's a problem because the question
then arises well what do you mean by
real exactly and exactly why
and you know then sam would say well you
can derive what's real from science and
i would say well there's an infinite
number of facts sam how the hell do we
decide which facts to pursue and which
not to pursue and which we shouldn't
pursue
and you think here's something
interesting about the scientific
literature
you write a research report about your
experiment you almost never tell the
truth about why you got interested in
that
what you do is you lay out this rational
argument that led to your hypothesis
which isn't what led to your hypothesis
at all by the way it's just a summary
statement that other people could follow
it's not an actual description of what
happened you're interested in something
for some reason
and that shapes your hypothesis and the
direction of your research and that's
tied in with your own personal narrative
so
it bedevils the scientific enterprise
and it can be a real problem because
your own narrative can you know cloud
your judgment of the let's say the
relevant fact
so
the epitome of that is this
mathematician named romana jan have you
heard of romantijn
yes
okay for those who haven't heard of him
he would come up through intuition or
through what he would say would be dream
encounters with gods or god it says
he would come up with what are
astounding
formulas that
i remember i think it was hardy who was
the supervisor said you can't simply
make these up they're too baroque for
you to make them up and they turned out
to be correct and what you're saying is
well okay how do you justify that well
that was one of the problems with him
what he would is that he would spit out
these formulas which in the end most of
the time turned out to be true slight
modifications of what's true and i'll
give an example if someone wants to if
someone can keep this in their head okay
so how many ways can you partition a
certain number so let's say 26 can be
written as one plus one plus 26 times or
it can be written as one plus two and
then plus one one so there are many many
different partitions of a natural number
he came up with this formula that the
number the partitions of any number
something like 1 over
2 pi square root 6 then you take the
derivative of what's happening here
which is exponential
1 over 2 pi over a square root of 6.
square root of n minus 1 over 24 all
over square root of n minus 1 over 24.
and he couldn't neces now i'm not sure
about that particular one doesn't matter
this is an example he couldn't prove
them and he would say that he just
they just occurred to him
so that to me is well i'm wondering well
that's a mystery there's no one else in
mathematics that was like that
and i'm not sure if that's because he
was terribly open like you mentioned
openness is a trait that allows you to
have this these
large leaps of insight i'm not sure if
that's exactly why it could be but
that's an example
yeah well you know the the
the the depths of what inspires us are
that's a great mystery right i mean one
of the mysteries of the scientific
enterprise for example is hypothesis
generation you know when we train
graduate students we we spend a lot of
time
training them in
method let's say
and approach and in writing scientific
papers and so on but there's almost no
strict
pedagogy in relationship to hypothesis
generation well where do you come up
with your research questions to begin
with well i'm interested in that it's
like well that's really not much of an
answer it's certainly not formalized
very well what what is that interest
exactly and how does it guide you
exactly and
what is that
and then you might say well and also how
is that related to your morality like to
what degree is your scientific
curiosity motivated by your own personal
desire for success or maybe the desire
to serve others you know on the virtuous
side
etc etc well that's just
that's just off in the domain of well we
don't ask those questions when we're
scientists and fair enough in some sense
but not really because well you do run
the kind of problems you just described
you know i work with this carver um
he's a member of uh
native canadian tribe no it's charles
joseph is his name and he's quite a
remarkable person and
he carves these traditional
west coast native canadian quack quack
and he dreams
in those images
and he consults with
the spirits of his father and
grandfather great grandfather in
particular in his dreams about his
carvings and he doesn't talk about that
with anyone because they think he's
crazy but he's not
he's definitely not
and he's a great artist in my estimation
unbelievably creative and that his
creative process is so
unique that
well it's remarkable to listen to him